- Oh hey, excuse me.
Are you a crypto exchange?
- Yep, that's correct.
You can call me SBF.
I'm a philanthropist,
and FTX is the third
largest crypto exchange
trusted by the one and only, Tom Brady.
- Yeah well, I got $8 billion here,
and I just need to put it somewhere safe
where I could trade.
Can you do that for me?
- Of course, my goal, my one goal,
is to do right by customers.
I'm a philanthropist.
- Okay well, this $8 billion
is really important to me.
- I understand, we're a 100% legit.
Just look at all these
appliances endorsing us.
- Oh my God, that is legit.
- It is really important that marketplaces
act in a responsible manner here.
It's not about how much money we make,
but it's about the impact we
can make to change the world.
I mean, I believe everything we do
is for the greater good of the ecosystem,
and for the end user.
Oh, did I tell you I was a philanthropist?
- Yeah, yeah. I just wanna make sure
that you understand how vital it is
for me to have access to these funds.
All right, here you go.
- Thank you.
Okay so, we're gonna deposit here.
And know that we hold our
customer assets one-to-one.
So, you have nothing to worry, oh!
Sorry, I slipped.
- Are you all right?
- Yeah, I'm fine, I just slipped.
- You still have my money, right?
- Oh yes, of course.
Yeah, here it is.
- Huh.
Yeah, it looks a little bit different.
But, I guess that's fine.
Anyways, thanks. I'm gonna head out.
(phone alert)
Holy shit!
Actually, could I have my money back?
- Oh yeah, no problem.
Just give me a minute.
Oh!
Here you go.
- Where's the rest of it?
- Fucking tokens!
- Now, I think after what happened,
it's even more important now than ever,
to self-store your crypto
with non-custodial wallets.
Which is why this video is
sponsored by 1Inch Wallet.
Now, this wallet is the
most friendly DeFi wallet
I've ever used.
You can store and transfer
all your crypto assets
on all these chains, like
Ethereum, BNB Chain, Polygon.
But most importantly,
it's a decentralized mobile app.
Meaning you own your own keys.
So unlike centralized exchanges,
your crypto assets aren't
managed by someone else.
If you want to interact
with a decentralized app,
you can use Wallet Connect.
For example, if I wanted
to connect to Opensea,
all I need to do is click Wallet Connect,
and then scan this QR Code.
There you go, now my wallet is connected.
So, if you need to store
your crypto somewhere safe,
and also easy-to-use,
check out 1Inch
Wallet on the app store or on Android
All right.
- It took me a while to find you.
- Shit! Get away you SEC!
- Relax, I'm not the SEC.
I'm assembling a team.